hemos visto que un compuesto o ion es
aromáticos y contiene un anillo de
orbitales para que se traslapan
continuamente y también si tiene cuatro
n más dos electrones en el anillo donde
n es un entero por ejemplo n podría ser
cero o uno o dos y así sucesivamente
podemos utilizar estos criterios para
analizar el canción ciclo prop en hilo
aquí está mi canción ciclo prop en hilo
y si veo cuántos electrones y tiene
serían dos electrones pi en el guión
déjame continuar escribiendo dos
electrones y aquí cuando veo los
carbonos en el guión este carbono tiene
un doble enlace por lo que tiene
hibridación sp2 lo mismo pasa con este
carbono y luego este carbono de arriba
este carbó catión también tiene
hibridación sp2 así que sabemos que los
carbonos con hibridación sp2 tienen un
orbital p libre cada carbono en este
long tiene un orbital p puedo continuar
mostrando eso en este diagrama
estoy dibujando el orbital p en cada
carbono de mi anillo y eso me permite
ver que mis orbitales p podrían
trasladarse de un lado a otro por lo que
este ión cumple con el primer criterio
tiene un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente y sé que los
orbitales peso nor vitales aromáticos y
tengo un total de 3
orbitales
tomic os
y de acuerdo con la teoría m esos tres
orbitales atómicos se combinarán para
darme tres orbitales moleculares y puedo
analizar los niveles de energía relativa
de esos orbitales moleculares utilizando
lo que es conocido como el círculo de
frost y ya hemos visto el círculo de
frost
continuaré dibujando una línea aquí para
dividir mi círculo a la mitad lo cual
divide mis orbitales moleculares en las
antes de mis anti enlazan test y siempre
empezamos en la parte de abajo de
nuestro círculo de frost e inscribimos
un polígono para que coincida con el
número de átomos en mi anillo en este
caso tengo un anillo de tres miembros
por lo que inscribir un triángulo dentro
de mi círculo de frost
intentaré dibujar un triángulo en mi
círculo de frost aquí y no es el mejor
triángulo pero lo importante aquí es
donde tu polígono inter seca con tu
círculo de frost eso representa el nivel
de energía de tus orbitales moleculares
puedo ver que tengo un total de 3
orbitales moleculares viendo mi círculo
de frost y cuando lo represento aquí sé
que tengo un orbital molecular aquí y
tengo dos orbitales moleculares aquí
arriba los orbitales moleculares en la
santé siempre tienen menos energía sé
que este orbital de abajo es mi orbital
molecular en la santé y por lo tanto
tengo dos orbitales moleculares anti en
las antes aquí arriba sé que tengo dos
electrones y de que preocuparme y es
completamente análogo a las
configuraciones electrónicas llenaré mi
orbital de menor energía primero y eso
sería mi orbital molecular en la santé y
solo tengo dos electrones
y esos dos electrones que llenarán por
completo mi orbital molecular en la
santé analicemos esto en términos de la
regla de hegel puedo ver que esto de
aquí sería 12 para representar mis 12
electrones pi y luego tengo 0 electrones
en mis orbitales moleculares santi en
las antes sería 4
4 x 0 es por supuesto 0 2 me da un total
de 2 la cual es la regla de juke así que
tengo 2 electrones bien el anillo y este
jon satisface el segundo criterio
también por lo que el camión ciclo prop
en hilo es aromático
si continúo escribiendo que este guión
es
agro
pico por aquí entonces es extra estable
y esta observación nos permite explicar
algunas de las propiedades asociadas con
esta molécula de aquí abajo que el ciclo
prop en onna la ciclo prop en onna tiene
una enorme cantidad de tensión angular
con un anillo de tres miembros aquí y
también tiene un momento dipolar
aumentado de lo que podemos esperar y
podemos explicar ambos
mirando la estructura resonante de la
molécula de ciclo prop en onna si pienso
en dibujar una estructura en resonancia
podría tomar estos electrones y moverlos
a mi oxígeno de aquí y entonces la
estructura resonante tendría mi anillo
tres miembros
de esta manera
y luego tendría este oxígeno con tres
pares libres de electrones alrededor
dándole una carga formal de menos 1
quitamos un enlace de mi carbono
carbónico de aquí por lo que ese carbono
tendrá una carga formal de más 1 puedes
ver que hemos formado el camión ciclo
prop en hilo aquí el cual sabemos es
extra estable
esto es aromático y mientras esta es una
estructura resonante extremadamente
menor para la mayoría de los compuestos
carbón y lycos para este este contribuye
un poco más al híbrido de resonancia por
la estabilidad extra asociada con el
camión ciclo propio en hilo el hecho de
que sea aromático y eso le da
estabilidad extra a esta molécula
y podemos también dibujarla
donde mostremos que la carga positiva
se extiende a través de nuestro anillo
de tres miembros así y luego tenemos
nuestro oxígeno aquí con una carga
negativa y esto nos permite ver el
momento dipolar ha aumentado un poco más
y ya que la parte en la izquierda es
extra estable como carga positiva esa
aromática eso significa que tenemos un
momento dipolar aumentado y también la
estabilidad aumenta a pesar de la
tensión angular significativa asociada
con la molécula del ciclo propano na así
que puedes utilizar el concepto de
estabilidad aromática para analizar la
estructura de otras moléculas también
hagamos un ejemplo más
veamos esta molécula que el ciclo
butadieno aquí a la izquierda tenemos
ciclo butadieno si veo los electrones y
aquí hay dos electrones y aquí hay otros
dos para un total de cuatro electrones
4 electrones
en mi molécula cuando miro los carbonos
cada carbono tiene un doble enlace por
lo que cada carbono tiene hibridación
sp2 cada carbono tiene un orbital de
libre y puedo dibujar mis orbitales aquí
en mi diagrama así esto hace un poco más
fácil ver que estos orbitales podrían
trasladarse de un lado a otro por lo que
el primer criterio se ha cumplido
tengo un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente
pero cuando veo mi segundo criterio
nuestro segundo criterio era 4 n 2
electrones
y no tengo eso tengo un total de 4
electrones pi y eso es realmente 4 n
donde n es igual a 14
uno es igual a cuatro
tengo 4 n electrones no tengo 4 n 2 ya
sé que mi compuesto no es aromático solo
viendo esto pero continuemos dibujando
nuestros orbitales moleculares y veamos
donde ponemos esos 4 electrones y en
nuestros orbitales moleculares mis 4
orbitales de aquí en este diagrama
significa que tengo un total de 4
orbitales atómicos para el ciclo
butadieno una vez más la teoría o m me
dice que 4 orbitales atómicos me darán 4
orbitales moleculares y puedo dibujar mi
círculo de frost aquí nuevamente
dibujaremos una línea a través del
centro para separar mis orbitales
moleculares en las antes de los anti en
las antes
siempre empiezas en la parte de abajo de
tu círculo de frost un anillo de cuatro
miembros
intentaremos dibujar una figura de
cuatro lados en nuestro círculo de frost
intentaré dibujar este cuadrado aquí
adentro
y otra vez donde nuestro polígono inter
seca con nuestro círculo representa el
nivel de energía de nuestros orbitales
moleculares
un total de
4 orbitales moleculares si voy para acá
tengo un orbital molecular por debajo de
la línea
ese es mi orbital molecular en la santé
tengo un orbital molecular por arriba de
la línea
ese es mi orbital molecular anti en
laxante y esta vez tengo dos orbitales
moleculares que están justo en la línea
los cuales representan orbitales
moleculares no en las antes continuo
poniendo mis cuatro electrones
nuevamente primero lleno los orbitales
moleculares de menor energía eso se
encarga de dos electrones y ahora tengo
dos más y aquí tengo los orbitales
moleculares no enlazan test están en el
mismo nivel de energía si recuerdas la
regla de junta de la configuración
electrónica no puedes aparear estos
últimos dos electrones pi porque los
orbitales son de misma energía y
entonces esto es lo que obtenemos y
puedes ver que tengo dos electrones de
sap área 2 y 2 electrones de sap área 2
implican que esta molécula es
extremadamente reactiva y
experimentalmente lo es por lo que el
ciclo butadieno de hecho reaccionará con
el mismo experimentalmente es
extremadamente reactivo lo que te indica
que no es extra estable no es aromático
no tiene 4 n 2 electrones bit por lo que
el segundo criterio no sé
pero este compuesto si satisface el
primer criterio por lo que el término
para este compuesto es anti aromático
anti
mate
lo que significa que cumple el primer
criterio un anillo de orbitales p sé que
se traslapan continuamente pero no
cumple el segundo criterio no tiene 4 n
2 electrones y tiene 4 n electrones pi
por lo que decimos que es anti aromático
y de hecho hay muy pocos ejemplos de
compuestos anti aromáticos pero el ciclo
butadieno es considerado anti aromático
en el siguiente vídeo veremos más
ejemplos de estabilidad aromática